this is from The Daily Mail quote I
don't understand why I'm sitting I'm
still sitting here my bags are packed
devastated Paul Whalen breaks his
silence from Russian penal colony as his
brother slams his catastrophic exclusion
from Brittany Greiner prison swap I'm
ready to go home let me show you the
truth
Jordan schechtel says NBC News a known
State propaganda Outlet is participating
in the cover-up operation first edition
versus stealth edited in the original
archive it says
but the official said Russia has treated
well indifferently because he is an
accused spy and that the Kremlin gave
the White House the choice of either
Griner or wellin or none they edit it to
say
the what they gave the White House the
choice of either Griner or no one after
different options were proposed
because the reality is Joe Biden had a
choice this former U.S marine
or a WNBA star no the WNBA Star hates
America as much as he does and is part
of the cult so this is what Joe Biden
chooses to do your values as an American
who believes in people sacrificing for
the greater good are not held by these
people and these are the people that
have near just just absolute raw power
in this country through ballot
harvesting or otherwise they control the
institutions and they are the I view I
view these people as a parasitic cult
that is suckling the blood from this
country and and gutting it ripping it to
shreds there's another aspect to this uh
prisoner swap deal that a lot of people
are missing and that was the involvement
of the Saudi Empire Saudi Arabia that by
the way the United States just declared
immune for the cash Hoagie killing they
literally cited Biden's administration's
executive powers and and and stopped any
further investigations and legal
responsibility for the killing of
kashoggi with Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia
country that negotiated this larger
prisoner swap with many people now
speculating that this was a part of the
deal of the United States getting uh
Brittany grinder back to the United
States and and it absolutely does make
sense because as we know Biden was
trying to do this before the midterm
elections in order to try to get
political uh favors in order to look uh
good to his base he wasn't able to
achieve that this Saudi Arabian
development does make sense now and it
wasn't just this former U.S vet that was
screwed over here but it was also the
family of kashoggi who also was
connected to intelligence agencies as
well that was screwed over here as well
so
it's like oh I mean Biden it's kind of a
smart move in my point in my opinion
over Weyland it's I dislike it but you
saw Micah Parsons on Twitter get
absolutely roasted for saying why is
Griner coming home and he's an athlete
famous athlete why is grinder coming
home and we have a a veteran overseas
and he got blasted by the the mob the
Twitter mob so Biden knows who's paying
attention to him you know
I just I just don't view view the the
leftists like the way I described it
several months ago was I don't care what
they think it's like asking me what the
people of France think about my opinions
like well we're not France you know I
don't view them and and this is not a
thing where
I'm trying to say this because I I'm mad
at this group of people or I don't like
them I genuinely don't think since the
pandemic when Biden came out and said
we're gonna lock down and I'm like but
red States aren't locking down I went oh
man we're two different countries that's
just it the left and right both agree we
are two different countries but a lot of
people on the right don't seem to get it
they keep saying our democracy and
people are like we don't live in a
democracy it's a constitution no bro
they're saying they have a democracy you
aren't a part of
so we got to do something but it's not a
democracy they say it's a democracy but
it's an oligarchy they're running it at
the top behind the scenes it's
administrators and yeah politicians and
bankers Deuteronomy that's a good word
bureaucracy I don't think bureaucracy
really gets to the element of the
economic function of a thought that's
why I say beeronomy because it's like
bureaucracy just implies there's like a
system of paperwork and you know
bureaucrats running things but it's also
the the system of self the system itself
of who gets access to resources is you
know the economic functions functions of
it it's not just oligarchy it's uh I
guess you can just call it classical
communism right like Chinese Chinese
Communist style that's what it is I
think they're losing you know so I'm
chill the the exposure that we're
getting out of the Twitter file stuff
that seeing what they're doing behind
the scenes and what the FBI has been
doing I'm like oh okay you know
they're going to lose they can't
maintain this but I think what what
helps is people realizing that uh
they're
you don't share a system with them
well I'm not sure with this story that
we need to really be focusing on on
Brittany and I just thought it was so
and what I mean by that is you know the
press secretary today was saying this is
a victory for the gay community and
black women everywhere and I'm like what
what does that have to do with anything
the fact of the matter is we traded a
terrorist an arms dealer that conspired
to kill Americans that is responsible
for deaths across the globe
to our enemy our adversary and I just I
I have to point this out I just uh it's
a terrible precedent and president quite
frankly that was set under President
Obama because I was looking at Bergdahl
and uh correct me if I'm wrong but
President Obama traded five Guantanamo
Bay uh individuals that were a part of
the Taliban for that for that one uh
American who apparently uh according to
sources had betrayed and run off and
then during President Trump we had
Americans that were freed from North
Korea we had the students that were
freed from China and we had Ayah hijazi
and her husband that were freed from
Egypt three different situations and
North Korea who could be more hostile
yeah I I think that is analogous to
Russia or China and president Trump
didn't have to trade an arms dealer or
terrorist in order to free those
American citizens and so that that needs
to be a part of the conversation has
nothing to do with identity gender Etc
it has to be at what point
do we concede in order to get something
back to America and furthermore I just
want to also make the point I think this
is not unexpected from the very
Administration that gave billions uh in
military equipment to the Taliban to
begin with so this is something that uh
I'm not surprised or shocked yeah I was
going to say what what this guy is
accused of doing is what the US
intelligence deep state has been doing
for a number of years now so let's just
call spade a spade here it's a he's a
very fascinating guy because he started
selling machetes and single shot rifles
to Africa then moved on to AK-47s uh he
was charged with conspiracy to kill
Americans the daa said a couple months
ago that his release would pose quote
grave national security threat to the
United States he's also alleged to have
tried to sell missiles to blow up U.S
passenger Airlines he is alleged to have
stolen 32 billion dollars of weapons
from Ukraine these are again all
allegations this is this is where the
movie by uh I forgot the title uh by um
what's his name that weird face looking
guy Quentin Tarantino no no sorry Quinn
I love you uh Nicholas Cage there's
Nicholas Cage movie oh yeah yeah yeah
that movie was good that movie was based
on this guy the oh really yes the in the
beginning of the movie is that where
that shows the bullet yep God of War God
of War yep I think that's no no hold on
Lord of War something like that someone
in the God of War someone in the chat
room will tell us but but his life was
uh you know depicted in that particular
movie by Nick and his cage can I just
you know the first thing I thought of
when I heard this like Luke's mentioning
this guy is like a wanted terrorist he
tried to kill Americans he's selling
missiles to us enemies he's it's we've
been warned that he's a tremendous
threat but we got Brittany Greiner and
the first thing I think of is Dumb and
Dumber when the dude rides up on the
little scooter on the on the moped and
then he's like what happened he's like I
traded the van for it 70 miles to the
gallon and he's like just when I think
you couldn't do you couldn't be any
stupider you go and do something like
this and totally redeem yourself
trading your van for a a pit bike that's
what this feels like we had The Merchant
of death and Biden's like well we do
need a d-list celebrity back in the
country that's what the that's what the
you know corporate media is calling him
and it was Lord of War the movie if you
haven't watched it yet I thought I
thought it was a great movie I was very
entertained by it and it's based off
real life Events off of this particular
guy now the other side of the story is
that a lot of this has trumped up
charges that this was personally
directed as a major political hit job
against Putin because he was pretty much
working within the Russian uh
intelligencia deep State selling weapons
where the Russian government couldn't
officially sell weapons too so again the
United States does this as well his main
crime was again financing Al Qaeda and
Isis and that's literally what the
United States did as well so your tax
dollars went to doing that this guy did
it as well and he was held and he was he
was held in uh captive in 2010 and was
supposed to send it was supposed to
sever 25-year sentence I got I I got
standards right yeah principles Brittany
Greiner should not be getting charged
and locked up like she was in in Russia
and all that stuff Americans for weed
right yeah it was uh a THC uh uh Vapor
or something and so so you know look I
think it's silly but she did break
Russian law I just don't you know and
you gotta abide by the rules but we can
we can do some kind of trade I got no
problem with that I think Brittany
Greiner should be back home United
States
um I'm just sitting here being like when
it comes to swapping the Lord of War
Merchant of death can't we do a little
better this has got to be like the worst
Biden needs to read the art of the deal
yes like because he has no idea how to
negotiate this stuff he just just traded
I'm saying a van for a pit bike yeah and
when you look at the way that uh Donald
Trump handled negotiations especially
when it came to prisoner swaps he did a
way better job especially when it came
to the situation in Turkey I believe
there was a pastor that was being held
there Donald Trump wanted him back in
the United States and then he started to
tweet about how the Lira was a crap
currency the currency started to go down
and turkey was demanding very uh tough
requests from the United States and then
ended up not giving up anything
according to the official story and the
way he handled that was I think a lot
better and again I'm critical of Donald
Trump you guys know that obviously in
the chat room I see it every single day
but I think the way he handled that was
a lot better than what Biden just did
now Biden's looking for a flash in the
pan he constantly looks for these like
little shocks bright light flashes to
keep people interested that's what it
seems like this is a publicity stunt
really more than anything for him I
think although I'm glad Britney's back
you know well let's be honest she was a
political prisoner right she was held up
there cap actively sentenced for eight
years in a very tough rush in jail I I
wouldn't want to to be in her situation
she was there because uh she was playing
basketball she was getting paid to play
basketball there and
um you know to me no one should be
charged for eight years for a substance
that they wanted to personally use
themselves to me that idea is just
absolutely insane so clearly the Russian
government was holding her as a
political pawn and clearly that
political Pawn played off and has been
incentivized by this larger trade deal
which at the end of the day only
incentivizes Russia to do this again to
other American citizens that are in
Russia if you really do think about this
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time